[Music]
hey wisecrack
share it again you might have noticed
that we have a soft spot for
cynical irreverent and even nihilist
comedy
but we've recently been wondering is
there anything on the other side
of our current cynicism is comedy based
in earnestness and genuine human emotion
still possible to answer this question
we're turning to our friend
beau burnham a comedian who might have
cracked the code for how to embrace all
the intellectual goodness of postmodern
irony
[Music]
while offering something with a real
human core can we get the house lights
up for a second and could you
let the lights on stage let the artifice
fade away now we're all the same
like a candy bar that has a hard shell
of cultural cynicism on the outside
but a warm hug from your favorite aunt
on the inside
even though burnham is still babyfaced
his work has actually gone through a few
distinct stages
while his earliest work incorporates
post-modern cynicism and ironic
detachment
i adopted a child from overseas to
rescue him from child labor factories
and on his very first birthday we went
to build a bear workshop
[Music]
his more recent work not only exposes
the meaningless core of contemporary
life
but also attempts to offer a corrective
with introspection and a search for
happiness
on a scale from one to zero are you
happy
burnham might be the rare comedic figure
able to offer salvation from the empty
cultural wasteland that is our modern
world
so welcome to this wisecrack edition on
the philosophy of beau burnham
and i guess spoilers part one how did we
get here
to understand why burnham represents
such an important shift in comedy
we first need to see how comedy arrived
at its postmodern era
and more importantly what the hell is
even meant by postmodernism
this phrase has become so amorphous that
it can be used to describe everything
from cars to scottish beer but a more
helpful understanding can be found in
the work of frederick jameson whose work
describes post-modernism as
the cultural logic of late capitalism
which means that each new form of
economic life creates a related form
of cultural life for example when you're
a poor college student your economic
situation dictates a cultural life of
cheap beers
movies in a dorm room and paying for
dollar cheesy roll ups with your laundry
quarters
when you graduate and get a job you're
drinking a locally made ipa
paying 20 for a movie ticket and using
your debit card for a cheesy gordita
crunch
a few years later you sell your app
flush finder that gives you a map of the
cleanest public toilets near you
and you'll be drinking aged whiskey
sitting courtside and sending your
scared assistant adrian
to grab you a crunchwrap supreme combo
each economic stage in your life leads
to a new cultural stage
and post-modernism is the cultural logic
of the current stage of economic
development which jameson calls
late capitalism now let's see how
jameson's ideas can help us better
understand these shifting trends in
american comedy over the past 70 years
we can do this with a three-step process
economic culture leads to popular
culture which leads to comedy
let's start in the 50s america isn't a
post-war boom
the gi bill has led to record numbers of
college grads and homeowners
it's easy to get a middle-class job and
cuba is just a quaint island of resorts
and cocktails
this era's popular culture is all about
optimism and enjoyment what are you
doing up here i thought you were
downstairs boxing chocolates oh they
kicked me out of there fast why
i kept pinching them to see what kind
they were
and their comedy sensibility can be seen
in someone like jack benny
congratulations boss why you just shot
with a peeled potato
by the mid-60s the boom time is over the
cold war has people on
edge and the vietnam war is on the
horizon there were protests
naked hippies and someone gave the
beatles lsd
the counterculture had snuck into the
popular culture and
lenny bruce is on trial for obscenities
while george carlin is listing them
and tits by the 80s reagan had promised
endless economic growth and we've got
cable tv to keep us company 24 7.
new media creates the opportunity for a
new breed of superstar
and while michael jackson sold out
arenas with his music eddie murphy did
the same with comedy but let's be honest
the most important thing is how fly they
look in red leather jackets
in the 90s comedians like jerry seinfeld
and ray romano had gone from successful
stand-ups to television stars
comedy was more mainstream than ever mtv
giant cell phones and economic growth
abounded and
all the while comedy rode this wave with
a new optimism and increasingly goofy
spirit
we're not worthy we're not worthy
but just like taco bell's nacho fries
good things can't last forever and by
the dawn of the 21st century
the dot-com bubble had burst limp
biscuit was popular and 911 left the
country wondering if anything could be
funny anymore
can we be funny
[Music]
why start now as the odds rolled on
things didn't get much better
the 2008 financial crisis was the worst
since the great depression
and the weird scrubs reboot left us all
wondering if nothing was sacred anymore
part two comedy as cultural cynicism
the political and economic cynicism of
the arts led to a new form of cultural
cynicism in the media
keep those on my nipples alone if you
don't [ __ ] like them go
squeeze on your dick while mostly known
for its groundbreaking character
prison mike the worst thing about prison
was that
was the dementors they were flying all
over the place and they were scary and
then they come down and they suck the
soul out of your body and it hurts
the office showed us the mundane and
often meaningless existence of the
american worker
and the rest of television was slowly
taken over by reality shows that were
all completely fake
but nobody seemed to care one of the
most recent shifts that helps us
understand the effect of late capitalism
on comedy
is what we're calling the adult swim
phenomenon what started as a way for a
cartoon network to get stoners to watch
their channel while eating double decker
tacos has since become the home of some
of the weirdest
most absurd and most intentionally
cringe-worthy comedy to hit the american
airwaves
tim and eric awesome show great job
showed us a surreal and absurdist
version of the upside down
stairs are pretty good eric andre
ironically occupied the space of the
late night host to show how
meaningless the late night model had
become while using interviews with
c-list celebrities to highlight the
vapid nature of contemporary fame
mr neighbor's house has recently shown
us what happens when mr rogers is put
through the post-modern cynicism filter
no matter what the color and when you
lie
you hurt your brother and of course our
friends rick and morty give us an
animated response to the classic
philosophical question
what if back to the future was an
r-rated movie involving the multiverse
nihilism
nobody gets it nothing you think matters
matters and lots of brown liquor
many of these shows weren't even funny
at least in the traditional sense
whereas the 90s and early aughts used
canned laughter to tell our lizard
brains when to laugh
eric andre used canned laughter to
create an uncomfortable moment for all
involved
maybe andre just wants to push the
limits of what we'll watch or maybe he's
asking if there's even such a thing as
authentic comedy anymore
we only know one thing's for sure though
just gotta eat the lettuces right just
straight up eat the lettuce
at the same time that adult swim is
blossoming occupy wall street is taking
over the streets of manhattan and young
people around the world are questioning
economic and political institutions in a
way that would make the mud-covered
hippies proud
but unlike their forefathers lenny and
george who use political cynicism to
infuse their comedy with an urgency
for truth got no steel industry left
can't educate our young people can't get
health care to our old people
but we can bomb the [ __ ] out of your
country all right
the adult swim generation let this
cynicism go from a rallying cry
to cynicism for cynicism's sake rather
than a response to a troubled world
this cynicism denied the existence of
real meaning or truth in the first place
just say smith again it don't matter
none of this matters
to return to the fourth meal of cultural
theory frederick jameson
this cynical comedy is a perfect
exemplification of post-modernism
the same cultural form repeats but this
time with iron
or to paraphrase marx first as johnny
carson then is eric andre eating his own
vomit
cynicism and irony led to a brand of
comedy in which truth
meaning and human earnestness are just
useless relics from the era of canned
laughter and pesky new york mothers
so are we now stuck in this postmodern
feedback loop of meaninglessness
maybe not but to find out we have to
return to our friend beau
nope the other one she's pretty but no
no
not the obama's portuguese water dog the
comedian lanky white guy in his 20s
yes finally jesus part three from irony
to sincerity in bo burnham
all right guys before we keep going reel
jared here for a minute
as you guys know we sometimes talk about
pretty heavy subjects
cynicism nihilism voids of meaning you
know the drill
but these topics can be to put it
bluntly a bummer
so that's why i want to talk about this
video's sponsored better help
a counseling service that allows you to
connect with licensed therapists on your
computer
tablet or mobile phone i actually tried
the service myself so wait till the end
of the video to hear more about my
experience
until then go to betterhelp.com
wisecrack to get started
and now back to bo bo burnham is an
interesting case
as much of his early work was shaped by
the influence of dutch absurdist hans
taywin where have you been
in jail for what rape
sorry i had no idea
and embodied a detached irony which
exemplified the tenets of postmodern
comedy if jesus can walk on water
can he swim on land because there is no
fixed standard of truth or meaning
burnham used comedy to point the
audience to the slack
jesus wasn't the messiah get back i'm a
heretic and i'm on fire it was oedipus
those holy nights the holy [ __ ]
but in his recent work
burnham pushes back against the
emptiness of post-modernism in an
attempt to find
genuine meaning in things like love and
happiness we could say that rather than
returning back to a modern perspective
burnham pushes through post-modernism to
arrive at a post-post-modern perspective
where the death of traditional meaning
is an opportunity for the creation
of new meanings we can see his
progression by considering his three
specials as three distinct stages in his
comedic development
his first special words words words
explores the death of art
and comedy the follow-up what goes a
step
further and operates under the principle
that meaning itself is dead
and his most recent special make happy
works through the death of meaning in an
attempt to see if
real meaning and happiness are still
possible from the opening minutes of
wordsworth's words burnham aims to show
the audience the facade of entertainment
it's all an illusion i'm wearing makeup
i'm wearing makeup makeup and for
burnham art is dead because it's really
just a means for
something else so people think you're
funny how do we get those people's money
true to the logic of late capitalism the
real purpose of art is simply creating
opportunities for making more money
and presumably eating nacho cheese
doritos local supremes whenever you want
and when he speculates on what the
forefathers of countercultural comedy
would think his conclusion
isn't pretty we're rolling in dough
while carlin rolls in his grave
his grave by pointing to the death of
art burnham shows how comedy has just
become a way for charming narcissists to
make as much money as they can
with no imperative for authenticity or
truth
if words words words is burnham's eulogy
for the death of art he goes a step
further
in what and mourns the death of truth
and meaning as such
heart is a lie nothing is real and he's
aware that in the context of people's
actual problems
laughter isn't the medicine we've been
sold that said laughter it's the key to
everything
it's the way to solve all the sadness in
the world
i mean not for the people that are
actually sad but the people like us that
gotta deal with them all the time
unlike the adult swim comedians burnham
doesn't just embrace the chaos that
comes from the death of meaning
he's asking what it means for us when
meaning dies
[Music]
and asking whether or not the creation
of meaning is possible
maybe life on earth could be
heaven but he has no conclusive answer
in what and he lets us sit in that space
of not knowing
[Applause]
if what is the point where he starts to
consider that comedy devoid of the
aspirations of any higher meeting is
just an equine atm
but we'll stop beating this dead horse
when it
stops spitting out muddy make happy
represents burnham's attempt to use
comedy not just for criticism but as a
vehicle to
search for meaning and he makes clear
early on that his comedy is
not a mode of escapism you are here
because you want to laugh
and you want to forget about your
problems
but i cannot allow it you should not
laugh
you should not forget about your
problems instead of escape
burnham tries to use comedy as an
occasion for the audience to truly
encounter their problems
and maybe themselves in the process
unless you underestimate burnham's
desire to make you think about some real
[ __ ]
the world is not funny twelve percent of
the world's population does not have
access to clean drinking water
the world is not funny guy fieri owns
two functioning restaurants
and while he has some facts wrong burdom
doesn't want to use culture as a way to
escape reality which is one of jameson's
worries about post-modernism that it
removes the imperative for us to be
critical about the world around
us like a server who lets you know that
he's upselling you on donkey sauce not
because it's good but because it'll make
him money
burnham lets us peek behind the
comedian's curtain
entertainers they are lying and they are
manipulating you it's not all harsh
reality for burnham though
as he thinks the move past cynicism has
some upside
we all deserve love
even on the days when we aren't our best
cause we all suck but love can make us
suckless we
all deserve love
it's the very best part of being alive
and i would know i just turned
25 and by adding that last line
he undercuts his own point showing us a
position that straddles the line between
naive optimism and ironic cynicism
the show ends with bo burnham's take on
a kanye west concert circa 2016
[Music]
and while it might start off with jokes
pringles listen to the people i am sure
90 of the complaint letters you get are
about the width of your cans just
make them wider he peppers this
confession with some more vulnerable
moments
i don't go to the gym cause i'm
self-conscious
and he closes out with what seems like a
genuine wish for his audience
thank you good night i hope you're happy
with make happy burnham harkens back to
the socratic tendencies from comedians
in a previous era much like the gadfly
of athens himself
burnham is urging his audience to truly
acknowledge their problems and
unhappiness
as the unexamined life is not worth
living and like aristotle his final
words imply that happiness might be
possible but we have to work at it
what's most interesting is that burnham
doesn't simply reject postmodern comedy
for the sake of something new
instead he pushes postmodern comedy to
its limits to see
what's on the other side and over the
course of these three specials we see
him transition from irony
to cynicism to earnestness or from the
death of art
to the death of meaning to the
possibility of meaningful art
after the death of meaning part 4 comedy
as a cure for despair
or is rick sanchez right now you might
be wondering
so what even if burnham thinks we should
try to be happy we live in a world where
goodness and truth seem increasingly
illusory and in a world where nacho
fries aren't even on most taco bell
menus anymore
is it even worth moving past post-modern
cynicism one telling factor is that
burnham isn't the only one
trying to inject a post-post-modern
sincerity back into comedy a great
example is the most critically
successful comedy film of 2017
the big sick which coincidentally stars
burnham as a comedian obsessed with
success
and while it's a genuinely funny movie
it explores family success
and love with a sincerity not common in
comedy films
and it's safe to guess that the
inclusion of ray romano isn't a
coincidence as we see the cranky sitcom
out of the 90s portraying a
complicated and compassionate human
being we've also seen this shift from
irony to sincerity in shows like nathan
for you
i mean the one i do look at you guys and
a part of me is envious
that you know i don't have someone in my
life that
is i'm this close with
and infusing absurdity with a story
about genuine adult friendship in
detroiters
and even one of the darkest shows out
there bojack horseman
explores the possibility of finding real
meaning it takes a long time to realize
how truly miserable you are
and even longer to see that it doesn't
have to be that way
only after you give up everything can
you begin
to find a way to be happy while
frederick jameson has yet to offer an
analysis of the way in which comedy can
cure the cultural illness of
post-modernism
it might just be the case that burnham's
work is telling us something about what
will happen
on the other side of late capitalism
either way
the crunchwrap supreme is here to stay
so maybe there
are eternal truths that we can all still
believe in